verkhovskiy and tanks in two directions once they
say scale and
dill un your client keeps minced meat
god from gawain he and
chris peeler from freud wrote pika have fun
we think and we mine faithful and such with and
wax wine and on and machine
in russia now military hysteria
it’s very difficult to break through to people’s consciousness
very good in the
past people
say when you ask them they say
it’s not by them
we can’t do it either it’s fake or it
’s actually done by Ukrainians but they pretend that
it’s us and these are the nicest people and
some  others say that
it was right to punish, in the end,
ukraine
should belong to russia,
i don’t understand how it turned around in the
public mind like this, at the
click of a button, i don’t understand of
course there are other people, there are a lot of them,
about half of those who
openly or
quietly but oppose  aggression
actually with these people we are conducting a
dialogue these people take to the streets of cities
these people are trying to sabotage what is
happening I am convinced  that the
awareness of what is happening in ukraine
will come to russia and
ingrid m.c.  oleg astakhov pink sands and
polite he sits and you get drunk to keep him
not speak out we see fix in everything
with the plane the effect was to sing the described
ivankov and west his expected
i expected that they are
not very brave people
mercenary people
as for whom their own wealth
it will turn out to be
more important than
thousands of human lives,
but some of them I hoped for some of them
and of course it upsets me
that they
behave like this today
do some of them come from
Ukraine
yourself how can you when your people are bombed
how can you not
take a clear position  and I don’t fully
understand this and
probably never will but I
accepted it ok significant enemies of the
shy buy diamond and mr andersen and
we will find him indulging is alive on this
path 3 and fu and
event hall your kind of gay and
get into the chat screen  and whether the catchers to the left
want everything or the folders on the singer
tiffin,
I have been at war with Putin for almost 20 years and
I
thought that I know the limits to which
he can reach, but
today this is
real  a real fascist from just without any
exaggeration without any swearing here
he is just a fascist a Russian fascist and yes
now I hate Putin it didn’t exist
before even when I was in prison and the
site view from below the Bukovina from offices fascist
admiring sensei fast new film now
something happened to him  which happens quite often
with elderly bandits, they
need to somehow explain their lives to themselves and
he saw a mission even
having acquired a mission from
becoming truly fascists, that is, the
person who
puts the mission
much higher than any number of
human lives,
he nevertheless remained bandits  and for a
bandit there is a very
specific specific attitude towards those
people with whom he
interacts, the
bandit is not ready to negotiate in the mode
you have it, I have it and
let's not touch each other, the
bandit believes that if you go
towards him without demonstrating
strength before that, then this means  you are afraid of him
if you are afraid of him he must put the squeeze on
you if you go again  if you meet him without
demonstrating strength, it means that you
are weak again and it is possible to put the squeeze on it, and this
is until you become literally a
slave so that we understand the stops for
him then there will be no danger
that today exists in the
negotiations of Western leaders such as
macron dan from baidan with putin they
are trying to persuade him without demonstrating strength, which means that in
his head some demonstrate weakness,
which means they can be pressed, this can
lead to that very world war and
[music]
in him on this be go and be and
tools with  trained from going to the commentary,
that is, about the troops and I don’t know if they have the
law of flutes to be pizza on screws so it
glues the connoisseur hellishly further Olga such
cook David Iphicles how else do you
manage to taste that date the
problem is that Western leaders are always
a step or a step behind  2
at the moment when Putin annexed
Crimea, he could really be stopped and
demonstrate his strength with real
sanctions instead of him  o they preferred to
pat on the head
when he attacked ukraine when it became
clear that he would attack ukraine
he could be stopped by
actually supplying ukraine with weapons nevertheless they
preferred to do it just a
little bit
when he had already attacked ukraine
it was possible to stop him and still it is
possible to stop him that  stop by introducing a
no-fly zone because this
eliminates the basic advantage
that Putin has over the Ukrainian
Ukrainian armed forces over the
Ukrainian people is the ability
to bomb them with impunity, fire
missiles from those points where they do not have to leave
if this moment is missed again the
next moment will be crossing the
border crossing the border  with Poland,
crossing the border with the Baltic States, he believes
that NATO does not exist, he is now
convinced of this, this is the
key mistake of the
West and Western leaders, you have not
dealt with bandits for a long time,
you always think that you can
give something to a bandit without
demonstrating that he is
calm down something  something and you can
calm down until you read the history of
your own countries, you all
went through it in the thirty-eighth thirty-
ninth year, then you just tried to
give Hitler something to Hitler to
calm him down and this led to a world war,
although in the thirty-eighth it can be  it was
stopped at all without any problems,
don’t worry, putin will be able to
tell the Russian people that he
won, but he himself must understand that he
lost,
he
wandered and
f-105
lavrentiy become eggs but anti-social
and
we will load her saiyan her stage
without any doubt  Yes, we are dealing with
Hitler, Yes, so far, without a history of genocide,
without a history of the Holocaust, but he is on the
verge of this
genocide and we will have a network with you for 20 years
with Christ to glue this it is in the fields
and within a vision of its finger is
a certain  workers kapeeets to the
state you return the amounts maria
putin use nuclear weapons
only if he is sure that he
will not receive an answer here he will be sure that
for  no one will stand
up for Ukraine, he can use nuclear weapons in Ukraine, then
he will convince himself that no one will stand up for Poland,
he will be ready to use
nuclear weapons against Poland
if he has a clear understanding that the
answer to the use of nuclear weapons
will be his unconditional death unconditional
death he will not  suicidal he was
suicidal he would not hide behind three
rings of protection and not chew his father sit down the
other end was even from his
close associates amen and swore and most of
all the bones of the bones they are not enough but
the nipple pavel features
for the horse sans
plus he will answer  we spoil the fittings of the
official and become you, I am a retinue and we
walked here and twists with knock down the sword through
sleep daiwa his words and
with
no unions hs brought on and
offence and so count down and
fairy at the goal you him to feel safe wife of
feels so it  was Beijing and
I read what he listened to what he said yesterday,
he used the word
national traitor and it is very interesting that we are
waiting for this word to be converted into Hitler and  we have
skype and
that's what i'm trying to say to
western people
if you say oh he uses
nuclear weapons and we're all going to die
let's give in to him here let's
give in further let's give in even
further
it means you will speak
to him as long as you  you will become just slaves,
I don’t admit it to myself and
I say to myself yes you can kill me, but
anyway I’ll die sometime,
so while I’m alive and I will live with
honor, as I think it’s right, and if you
kill me, what can I do  than I am better than
everyone else who died before me and will die
after me you can’t retreat under threat
you can’t otherwise life will be
very dirty until its funky simak in the morning
and its china khaki vegetable year
thanks thanks to understand her scenes